hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the pro slogan a
short work by Anselm of Canterbury is
largely known by most people within the
world of ideas if they indeed know of it
at all because of something that's often
called the ontological argument which
occurs in chapters two through four of
the work and which you can actually call
out of chapter 2 itself and Ansem didn't
intend the work to center solely on that
in fact he talks of a single argument
running through the entirety of the work
and the ontological really so called
ontological because it's not an Psalms
terminology for that but rather that of
much later authors like Immanuel Kant
the argument there is only a piece of a
much larger and much more complex single
argument that runs through almost all of
the work so what is that argument if we
want to understand that the first place
to go to is not the argument itself it's
actually the introduction or premium to
the work itself where he tells us
why he has written this and he tells us
about his motivation anthem had
previously written another much longer
work called the Mona lo Geum and this
one was as he calls it here a whole set
of connected arguments it was a molt
autumn concatenate I own a context of
argument horn so there were multiple
arguments argument autumn is the plural
of that and they were woven together and
and in some respect kind of heaped up
upon each other and they were dealing
with different aspects of the divine
substance and its relations with the
human knower and lover and and being and
with the rest of creation and Ansem he
wasn't quite happy with the Mona loggia
he said I wanted to see if I could find
a single argument
Unum argumentum right a single you could
say demonstration or explanation some
sort of logical some sort of rational
account and this one would require no
other so it would be you could say self
grounding it wouldn't require some other
arguments to provide the original
premises for it it would work on its own
so that's one key aspect of this unum
argumentum then he said that he thought
about it a lot and he struggled with the
idea and at first he didn't really make
any progress as a matter of fact it's
really great to hear it in his own words
he says that I turned my thoughts to
this with great diligence sometimes I
thought I could already grasp what I was
looking for and sometimes it escaped my
mind completely finally I gave up hope
I decided to stop
looking for something that was
impossible to find so it's difficult to
find something that doesn't require any
other grounding or argument and it's
also difficult to you know make one wrap
one's head around these these sort of
complex matters to begin with so he
struggled with the argument and then he
rejected it and then after he rejected
it like any sort of thought that you say
I'm never gonna think about this what
happens to you he says I a flit or
repress it altogether lest by occupying
my mind with useless speculation to keep
me it would keep me from things I could
actually accomplish then it began to
hound me to pursue me more and more to
impose itself upon me that's an
interesting way to talk about a line of
thinking isn't it it's not just an
argument in the sense of some things set
down on paper an psalmist is thought he
has in mind here living thought and he
tells us that he has this struggle and
he rejects it and then he has sort of a
breakthrough he says I resisted it and
fought against it then one day when my
violent struggle against a town and
warned me down the thing I despaired of
finding presented itself in the very
clash of my thoughts and then he says I
eat early embraced that thought the
latin is um comes from the word to sort
of go around he actually says here we go
yeah I when I was worn out with
resisting it's important see imported to
nathie I eagerly grasped the notion
studio so koga Tatyana complex erector
qualm so the key to repel a bomb I
grabbed it I wrapped myself around it so
he embraced it now what was this
argument supposed to do we're going to
get to that in a moment usually
we think of arguments as a matter of
convincing other people we provide
arguments so that we can get other
people to agree with us to see things
our way
and when it comes to arguments about God
we often call this apologetics and the
idea is well we can take an unbeliever
and provide them with an argument and
they will become a believer thereby and
acknowledge that there must be a guy
that is not what Ansem was trying to do
in writing this down he tells us that he
actually had a primarily esthetic motive
what do we mean by an aesthetic motive
well he says that he was so filled with
joy at finding this argument that he
thought that he would share it with
others and thereby give them enjoyment
or pleasure and so by setting it down
he's not simply trying to convince
people that God exists he's trying to
give them a line of thought that will be
in fact enjoyable for them to dig into
so what is this argument supposed to do
he actually tells us and this is a very
important point that it's going to do
three related kinds of things so the
first thing is to demonstrate or to
prove or - how else should we put it to
lead a person through understanding
progressively more and more odd odds
through Enda min Latin which is not to
simply prove but to demonstrate so the
argument is supposed to demonstrate that
God exists but he doesn't just say God
exists Deus si he says God truly or
really exists Deus Vera asked right so
there's already an interesting emphasis
there as a matter of fact in the the so
called ontological argument he's going
to use the besides the term esse being
Oreste is in Latin he's going to use the
term
existence to exist in such a way that
that it sort of puts itself out there in
the original sense of the term so that's
one thing but then there's another
motive that's equally important for this
single argument running throughout the
prose low June that God is the supreme
good demonstrating that needing no other
requiring no other and going further
that all other things have need of in
order for them to have being that is
esse and in order for them to be well
bennett esse
so you could say well first you have to
prove that God exists and then you can
prove this other stuff in existence is
more important for Anselm existence does
come first in the order but the being of
God is goodness the being of God is to
be this supreme good that all other
goods require and that gives all other
things their being and their being well
these are not separate moves within the
movement of thought right they're all
part of the same thing then the other
thing that he says that this argument is
supposed to prove is really a set of
other things as we see whatever we
believe about the divine substance so
here he's talking about the things that
religious believers and here he of
course he has in mind
Western Catholic Christians whatever it
is that they believe about the the
divine being or divine substance
cweickum queda Divina credi most
substantive and he says that we want
this argument to suffice to do all of
these things now if you examine the work
itself the pros lo Jian in its structure
what do you find and here I've got sort
of a summary of the different chapters
this is very important
the very first chapter you might not
consider that to be part of the argument
he calls at an exit axial mentis and a
rousing of the mind and what is the the
point of that to the contemplation odd
quantum condom dayum and you notice that
in that he is trying to you know he's
talking to his own mind his own soul
saying stir yourself up little man try
to raise your thoughts but he's also
lamenting his damaged condition
something that will become a theme later
on when he talks about how he kind of
understands God but also doesn't
understand him he doesn't see God even
though he's seeking Him and why is that
it's not because there's something wrong
with God but because there's something
wrong with him and he prays in this he
asks God to form and reform him now
that's a weird way to start a treatise
on the nature of God or the existence of
God is it not to be talking to the very
being whose existence you're
demonstrating two through four are the
what so-called ontological argument in
Chapter two he gives you the famous
argument that begins from the idea of
God or not a definition but a
characterization of God as quote mayest
kogatana renown posit that is that then
which greater cannot be thought or a
greater cannot be thought he changes the
terminology a little bit every once in a
while he changes post it into valley yet
or he changes the the wording around
from time to time that it holds fairly
constant what's most interesting about
this he doesn't just use that for
chapters 2 through 4 where he's talking
about the existence or being of God he
is actually using that throughout the
rest chapters 5 through 23 where he is
also talking about the good
of God and exploring that topic at
considerable length goodness in terms of
power goodness in terms of justice and
mercy goodness in terms what whatever
else God gives you no life reason and he
actually gets us to the point within the
middle of these chapters where God is
not just that then which a greater
cannot be thought but God is greater
than what can be thought thought that is
by human beings so all these other
matters are being considered their even
matters of eternity or whether God is a
Trinity there's a lot packed into that
set of chapters and that is all part of
this single argument it's all beginning
from the same basic starting point
characterizing not defining by the way
and some is very careful to say when
he's being criticized that he is not
providing a definition of God he is
simply saying God is that then which
nothing greater can be thought and
showing what some of the consequences of
that would be for the attentive human
mind who wants to follow it out the last
three chapters are not part of the unum
argumentum the single argument they are
you could say added on they are to use
the title of the very first one of them
conjectures or speculations connect
taught Co and we could say cognac
Tatiana's in in the plural right and so
they go beyond the scope of the argument
itself and they're primarily about what
it's going to be like to enjoy that good
in heaven so they're quite interesting
you might also say that in a certain
sense it's not part of the unum
argumentum but it's a rather commentary
on it the monk danilo the critic of an
some who primarily targets chapters 2 3
or and says everything else I'm I'm good
with that and an Psalms response to
Canelo those and some ordered to be
copied along with the pro slow Jian so
they really are part of the work but
they are not part of the unum argumentum
the unum argumentum really runs from
chapter two to chapter 23 and it
encompasses all of these different
things understood as being interrelated
so the unum argumentum is not the
ontological argument the ontological
argument in fact is not an argument in
the sense that Ansem is using it here
because he's claiming he has a single
argument that what we call the
ontological argument is just a portion
of
you